that's one update on Raven the cat from
Alabama that was found here in Las Vegas
so many of you have reached out to us
wanting to get help get raven back home
after we aired her story and it has paid
off Victoria Saha gives us an update
tonight
come here baby just for a second Raven's
gonna have to pack up her bags she will
soon be on her way home after going
missing from her Alabama home in 2021
this curious Kitty made the nearly 2 000
mile trip to Nevada all alone and was
found this month in a neighborhood in
North Las Vegas helped heal the eye
Elizabeth mcloyd has been taking care of
Raven but wasn't sure how to get her
home she's scared and she wants to go
home I just don't have the funds to get
her there but ever since our story first
aired on Raven our viewers in Las Vegas
and across the country stepped in when
the story aired 11 of our followers
tagged us on it to see if we could help
Teresa Deckard is with imagine home a
non-profit that ground transports cats
across the country and will be in charge
of getting Raven home and I thought wow
it's gonna take us two weeks to get her
home that was my first fight and with
your help they are able to do this
dozens of emails flooded into our 8 news
now Newsroom with viewers wanting to
donate to Raven's trip back to Alabama
Deckard says they usually Drive their
cats to their destination but since
Raven is so far from home she will be
boarding a plane to Alabama for her
owner Tracy cost will be eagerly waiting
for her I thought I was never going to
find her again I thought she was gone
forever Raven's trip and medical
clearance will be costing about one
thousand dollars a gold Deckard says was
met within 48 Hours of Raven's story
captivating the nation Victoria Saha 8
News now
wow Amazing Story right since Raven was
on the road for nearly two years she
needs to be seen by a vet first to get
updated vaccines and take care of some
minor injuries her owner hopes Raven
will be on a Plane by the first week of
March